[Música]
que le diga que ya nos sentimos seguros
es una mentira no sí porque pues sabemos
que hay un riesgo ante todo para todos
nosotros pero bueno pues estamos
adaptando a vivir con esas condiciones
le es muy difícil decir que ya nos
acostumbramos o que no pasa nada con esa
seguridad porque no es cierto De
antemano sabemos que sí pasa algo que
sabemos que estamos en una zona de
riesgo pero pues nosotros estamos al
pendiente de las lo que digan las
para tener una evacuación nosotros como
autoridades de aquí de este pueblo no
tenemos un apoyo suficiente con qué
transportarnos Y esto complica las cosas
complica las cosas porque por ejemplo en
un momento dado que aquí sí llegar a
hacer erupción de verdad con qué nos
vamos
Entonces sí necesitaríamos ayuda de
nuestro gobierno